hola su majestad qué puedo hacer por
usted
una emergencia en carga la estatua de la
cabeza de mi padre y no estoy segura de
que sea del tamaño correcto y cuál es el
tamaño correcto bueno como sabes en
nuestro reino tenemos la tradición de
medir las cosas en términos de cuadros
azules de fantasía sí sí estoy enterada
a mí también me gusta medir cosas en
términos de cuadros azules de fantasía y
por ley
las estatuas de oro nuestro reino deben
tener la altura de cuatro cuadros azules
de fantasía ok es apareció una ley muy
razonable y cuál es el problema pues que
no estoy seguro de que la estatua mida
cuatro cuadros azules de fantasía bueno
cálmense creo que podemos revisar esto
tengo varios cuadros azules de fantasía
por aquí porque no los ponemos cerca de
la estatua para ver si la altura es de
cuatro cuadros azules de fantasía
exactamente
ok su alteza adelante porque no inicia
usted
eres tú aquí tengo 12
y tres cuadros azules es fantasía
tres cuadros azules de fantasía
alto ahora
reina cálmense no creo que debe entrar
en pánico porque si vemos la forma en la
que acomodo los cuadros bueno es
emocionante los cuadros están flotando
los cuadros azules de fantasía están
flotando así es pero si queremos medir
no debe haber espacios entre los cuadros
azules de fantasía debemos estar seguros
de que los cuadros queden muy juntos
porque no trata de nuevo vamos a quitar
estos cuadros azules de aquí y adelante
es su turno nuevamente está bien
espacios entre los cuadros eso tiene
todo el sentido del mundo
mira no estoy dejando espacios si eso
está bien continuar no me interrumpas ok
adelante su alteza continue 3
y 5
esto es un desastre la estatua debe ser
de cuatro cuadros azules de fantasía no
de cinco okay reina no se atormente el
tamaño de la estatua podría ser correcto
lo que pasó ahora es que no inició en la
base de la estatua inicio por debajo y
por otro lado terminó más arriba que el
borde de la estatua por eso aparece que
son cinco cuadros pero eso es incorrecto
hoy estoy tan confundida podrías hacerlo
por mí bueno creo que sería mejor si lo
hace usted misma sólo recuerde que
debemos empezar a medir en la base de la
estatua y terminar de medir en el borde
de la estatua y que no debe haber
espacios entre los cuadros azules de
fantasía no me siento cansada pero ahora
este último intento es buena idea que lo
intente de nuevo está bien que hagamos
un esfuerzo adicional aquí voy esta es
la base de la estatua así que voy a
empezar a acomodar los
los azules de fantasía desde aquí y este
es el borde superior así que debo llegar
hasta aquí
1 2
pero voy a dejar ningún espacio 3
y la altura correcta tiene exactamente
cuatro cuadros azules de fantasía de
altura esto será maravilloso para el
palacio muchas gracias de nada sal tc